It's so, you know, you know,
you do Jujitsu, it's fun.
So everybody wants to just slap hands,
punching knuckles and start rolling. Yeah,
it's fun. It's fun. It's like a fun game
you're doing. It's a good release. Yeah.
But the best way to get better
at it is to constantly drill.
And then you develop these pathways that
are just ingrained in your subconscious.
And so when you're in
that half guard position,
you immediately go for that under
hook immediately. You know the path,
you know where to go instead of ad
libbing and thinking while you're in the
middle of a role.
And when you see guys that come
from camps where they don't drill,
they only do like one technique
at the beginning of the class,
you'll notice a technical deficiency as
opposed to like someone who comes from
Hixson school or someone who comes from
a school that's very technical or you
know, the Mendez brothers or
something. You know, it's just,
it's so important to look at this,
look at the sport,
whether it's MMA or kickboxing or Jujitsu,
whatever it is,
but to look at it like a,
like a puzzle,
like you're trying to figure out what's
the best way to solve this and you know
what Duane is done for you.
It's been pretty remarkable as far as
like giving you footwork skills and tools
to move around and angles and I,
you know,
I've watched you guys dry
drill and train together.
I mean it's really amazing stuff.
Yeah.
Stuff that we think is simple and then
we'd go and teach it to the gym and
they're like, wait, what? Can you
guys do that like 10 more times?
When you see that again, it's
like, oh right. All right.
So we've just been doing like the full
work I've created with Dwayne the,
he wasn't a full word guy when he fought.
He was trained that crunchies are
natives and then like he's the one that's
creating all these angles with me and
now we've created a whole new style.
It's so funny that he saw that kind of
while he was fighting and then after he
was fighting, he's implementing and on
new fighters and didn't do it himself.
And he laughs about it. Yeah. He,
he wishes he probably would
have had someone like himself.
Coach him obviously walked in for
sure. Yeah, everybody does. Yeah.
He's a fucking wizard man. Yes. Cause he
didn't stop thinking about it either to,
he's like the same Kalvia for strike.
I'ms I'm telling you like I have all
the best coaches in the world around me.
Like he's like same Kalvia
of striking and MMA. Um,
and I'm trying to convince him to come
to southern California and started
professional fight team so that we can
help recreate what we do for everyone
because trying to get them to move out
here, but he loves Colorado. He does.
But he also loves being the best
coach in the world. Any anyhow,
so I'm hoping that I can convince him
enough that he, he'll do that. You know,
closely think you are to convince them.
I think I'm close.
[inaudible] I know you're, listen brother,
I know you want to come to California.
I've never seen anybody with this
detailed, um, uh, an instruction manual,
like the way he breaks down his
system, no matter for striking. I mean,
it's really remarkable. Even when
he comes into here to talk to you,
he'll have a system that you need to
tell him what he wants to talk about,
what he wants to do.
Like the guy doesn't stop thinking he is,
he's on top of his stuff. He's OCD in
a good way. Yeah. And the best way,
the best way. Absolutely. Well, it's like
you were saying about being competitive.
I mean,
I think it's you,
the idea that you're going to be this
balance chilled out person and still be a
fucking world.
Smasher good luck with that.
I'm the farthest thing from relaxed and
chill, you know, I tried to learn it now,
but yeah, but when you're
training and when you look you,
there's a mindset that's required to
beat the best guys and it's not the same
mindset that's required
to get good to get,
you could get good and be a chilled out,
relaxed person.
Like say you want to be a black belt
in Jujitsu, that's totally possible.
You can be really good people
and go, Hey, look at Mike Mann.
Mike has got a great triangle. Watch
them roll. Wow, he's really good.
But if Mike wants to be the motherfucker
have motherfuckers, you better be crazy.
You know,
you better be God damn crazy.
You better be like Mike Tyson when he
was young and be those Michael Jordan's
yet talking about, they're always thinking
about it. [inaudible] Jones Jr yes.
All of those guys. You've got to be
a fucking crazy person. Absolutely.
Everyone's Roy Jones Jr
played a professional
basketball game the day of his
fight. Played a guy named basketball
games do and he's just an athlete. Yeah.
Yeah. I mean, I just don't think
there's any other way, you know? I mean,
I think if you're going to win a race,
you're going to red line the engine.